[Music]
Three,
two,one.
I never forgot a lyric.
[Laughs]
[Applause]
[Music] I
admit it.
[Applause]
[Music]
I do it too
Then,
unnie, tell me about it. Our
birthday is
going. Let's
start with
unnie.
Music]
[Music] It's
like shabu-shabu,
right
[Music]
Style, style, feeling
But I'm curious about this, but
I'm curious about
Dawon from the beginning
So
[Music]
Three,
two,one
But we
were facing each other, but
we had to shoot, but we kept laughing.
Oh, I know
what it is, I know what it is,
but I say it's Unnie Chaewon. From my
standpoint
[Music]
But at least
three,
two,one
Eunchae
[Music] If the
other person doesn't want to go out, I don't want to be shy either
[Music]
I'm a tiktok player Get
down
I didn't come out to go, so Yujin-ah, you're
smart, so Yunjin-ah, it must have
happened then, oh my go,
but I prepared it in 3 minutes and came out.
[Laughs]
Arrived
Really
ah I think there
will be hundreds
10 times, 10 times to 9 times is a
reaction Ah,
but the two of you, the two of you
[Music]